[Musica]
siamo qui per parlare di design però
parliamo di design in una maniera
diversa nel senso non dovete pensare
all'arredamento per un momento
dimentichiamoci completamente
l'equazione design uguale sedia perché
siamo qui di parlare per parlare di
quello che in realtà ci permette di
usare il cellulare con facilità quello
che permette di fare operazioni di
microchirurgia di sicuro successo
pensiamo al i viaggi nello spazio che
sono ormai in un futuro molto prossimo
se ne parla davvero in termini concreti
quello che sarà in grado di farci
viaggiare di farci avvitare forse nello
spazio chissà con comfort fisico e
mentale passa sicuramente attraverso il
design non è una novità perché in realtà
di interazione tra la progettazione e
altre discipline
se ne parlava già ai tempi di leonardo
da vinci e se pensiamo agli anni 50 60
dei maestri del design italiano come
mario bellini ettore sottsass già
disegnavano degli oggetti elettronici
però oggi è successo qualcosa di
completamente diverso
innanzitutto perché perché il design non
interagisce più solo con quelle che sono
delle discipline scontate a cui ci viene
facile pensare ma hanno a che fare col
design le guerre la scuola l'analisi dei
grandi dati la psicologia alla biologia
oggi si parla di disegnare molecole
quindi il discorso è molto diverso e
questa interazione è diventata
sistematica
attenzione però questo non significa che
tutti sanno fare tutto perché la
specializzazione rimane una priorità
si tratta di imparare a dialogare a
conoscersi a capirsi e a trovare un
territorio comune su cui lavorare ognuno
con le sue capacità co apportando le sue
competenze
con un obiettivo comune in realtà di
interaction design si parlava già in
america negli anni 80 e all'epoca si
intendeva con questa parola
nello specifico parlare dell'interazione
fra l'uomo e
tecnologia l'informatica è da lì che
dobbiamo la nostra capacità o incapacità
di usare un computer
un'interfaccia facile accessibile come
quella di google è passata attraverso un
dialogo che ha visto degli ingegneri dei
designer dei grafici collaborare insieme
oppure ancora un esempio un sistema
domotico che ci permette di controllare
la sicurezza le luci riscaldamento in
casa e via dicendo questo è successo
perché i designer hanno imparato a
parlare con gli ingegneri gli psicologi
comportamentalisti gli esperti di
ergonomica gli scienziati dei materiali
e quindi si può parlare veramente di una
collaborazione a 360 gradi
questa diciamo oltre a essere forse la
prima volta in cui interaction design
viene viene definito e gli viene dato un
ambito è anche la prima esperienza
diretta che noi abbiamo l'interaction
design è la prima esperienza diretta e
forse la più frequente nell'uso della
rivoluzione
una vera e propria rivoluzione
tecnologica e scientifica che stiamo
vivendo in questo periodo
detto questo dobbiamo pensare però una
cosa è il design thinking è un approccio
è un modo di pensare che deriva dal
design che è diventato fondamentale per
tutte quelle aziende quelle persone o
tutti quelli che vogliono fare
innovazione e questo richiede una
caratteristica in particolare che è
l'elasticità mentale per fare dei passi
avanti veri è necessario abbandonare un
po di preconcetti un po di abitudini un
po di rigidità accademiche e c'è un
altro dettaglio da considerare poi
passiamo agli esempi però voglio dirvi
ancora una cosa il design a che fare con
l'uomo
il soggetto degli studi di un designer
degli sforzi di un designer è sempre e
comunque l'uomo ed è per questo che
spesso nell'interazione con discipline
che magari sono più asettiche o più
lontane da noi
l'intervento del design permette che una
scoperta magari geniale ma lontana dalla
nostra quotidianità di 20 si trasformi
si traduca si parla proprio di
traduzione
da parte del designer in un oggetto di
uso comune noi non abbiamo bisogno di
sapere necessariamente che cosa c'è alle
sue spalle
detto questo questa piccola premessa non
così piccolo io ho curato nei mesi
scorsi nel mese di novembre una fiera di
design indipendente
un festival di design indipendente che
si è tenuta a torino e si chiama opere e
nella selezione dei designer noi abbiamo
lavorato proprio in questo senso abbiamo
scoperto che i designer non solo via via
che insomma passano le generazioni si
sentono sempre più consapevoli della
complessità del sistema in cui
interagiscono consapevoli delle scelte
che fanno anche responsabili e in più
danno questa interazione con discipline
anche impensabili come parte strutturale
del loro lavoro della loro celle ricerca
vediamo qualche esempio in questo caso
edgar flop è un designer bretone
francese che vive vicino al mare e come
potete vedere a una passione smisurata
per il mare e in particolare per essere
questo oggetto che si chiama liu barista
è una tavola da surf disegnata insieme a
dei veterinari e realizzata insieme ad
artigiani studenti locali
come vedete il principio quello della
spina di un pesce la lisca vera e
propria su cui è stata disegnata una
tavola quindi questa collaborazione
veterinario designer ha permesso di
creare un oggetto inedito che funziona
molto diversamente dalle tavole a cui
siamo abituati perché è un oggetto che
reagisce istintivamente sulle sulle onde
e quindi il designer mi diceva devi
provarlo per capire di cosa parlo non
sia una performance atletica per cui
occorre essere preparati eccetera ma
basta abbracciare questa tavola e
teoricamente sì morta con un pesce in
più
i materiali sono naturali sono resine
fibra di cellulosa legno il designer ha
proprio voluto evidenziare questa questa
struttura animale e quindi rendere
esplicita questa collaborazione
questo è un progetto diverso sempre una
designer italiana giulia tomasello
che vive a londra questo è il suo
progetto per finale per il master in
material fusion che lei ha fatto centro
a san martin ed è un kit appunto questo
kit futures flora permette di coltivare
in casa molto facilmente dei batteri per
prevenire la candida la candida
un'infezione vaginale che colpisce il 75
per cento delle donne con questo kit
estremamente semplice come vedete anche
nelle istruzioni sembra quasi un
montaggio che ha le persone sono in
grado senza utilizzare farmaci senza
spese eccessive di gestire una parte
importante della propria salute e anche
in questo caso c'è una collaborazione
con un con una disciplina scientifica in
questo caso sono le bioscienze che hanno
permesso di sviluppare questo kit che
per ora è ancora a livello di prototipo
non ancora commercializzato questo
lavoro invece geo merce di giornata
gatto e giovanni innella in questo caso
parliamo di terreni inquinati dai
metalli pesanti la scoperta la scoperta
una cosa che in realtà si sapeva la
ricerca muove sullo studio delle piante
iper accumula trici che sono piante in
grado di estrarre nichel rame zinco fino
a 200 kg per ettaro all'anno
il lavoro dei designer è stato insieme
in collaborazione col laboratorio
internazionale di neurobiologia vegetale
il dipartimento di bioscienze della
facoltà dell'università di parma e
laboratorio di plant science di wagen
again è stato
l'intuizione ad associare alle radici di
queste piante estrattive dei sensori che
sono in contatto con la borsa dei
metalli e quindi il vostro territorio
inquinato il vostro terreno pieno di
rame diventa una ricchezza immediata
perché comunque sia avendo questa questa
interfaccia diretta con il mercato dei
metalli può vendere nel momento migliore
eccetera eccetera ap la ricerca va
proprio in quella direzione quella
dell'investimento diretto un altro
lavoro
gli ex machina mette insieme biologia
robotica e computazione digitale ovvero
una stampante 4d in grado di stampare
funghi lavorare coi miceli in questo
caso la collaborazione tra maurizio
montalti e la sua officina corpuscoli
che uno studio di design e di ricerche
sperimentazioni transdisciplinari con sé
ed amsterdam il centro di computational
design italiano code it e il dg
factoring questa macchina che vedete che
esiste che sta lavorando a torino in
questi giorni proprio sta creando questi
prototipi a vederli così dicono poco
però considerate che questi prodotti
progettini questi oggettini sono in
grado di autori di autoripararsi di
crescere seguendo una guida che noi
possiamo dargli e di adattarsi quindi è
un materiale un dio materiale adatto a
biocostruzioni rivoluzionarie comprese
quelle spaziali per questo l'agenzia
europea spaziale fa parte di questo di
ricerca insieme all'università di uther
altra altro progetto concreto reale
questa è un'area urbana e sia
manifactory a un progetto del designer
francesco fascì sviluppato insieme a un
apicultore urbano che si chiama mauro
vetta è stata installata per la prima
volta nel giardino della triennale a
milano permette di far convivere le api
in città proprio in centro città
l'altezza di 4 metri e mezzo non la
rende non pericolosa e il vetro consente
soprattutto ai bambini di vedere che
cosa accade all'interno questo tra
l'altro appena stata acquisita anche
dalla città di seul che ne sta
impiantando 20 nel centro della città
nei parchi urbani nel centro della città
perché entro il 2020 se uno vuole
rendersi autonoma dal punto di vista
dell'alimentazione
questo è un progetto molto importante
perché aiuta anche a sconfiggere dei
preconcetti nei confronti delle api che
sono fondamentali per la biodiversità e
che stanno estinguendo sì lo sappiamo
tutti
mar le whif altra designer francese sta
a londra lei ha lavorato in questo caso
quella che vediamo e propoli nera lei è
figlia di apicoltori quindi in questo
caso l'interazione nasce in seno alla
famiglia proprio e lei studia questi
materiali dal punto di vista della
lavorazione in questo caso appunto lei
lavora con le api comuni ha collaborato
con artigiani anche di murano per
soffiare la propoli come se fosse vetro
inciderla eccetera e quindi studiare le
potenzialità di questo materiale
questi sono bachi da seta indiani a
partire da questi l'ha inventato proprio
un materiale che si chiama wooden lega
che ha le qualità tanto del legno quanto
della pelle pensate al potenziale in
termini di abbigliamento o rivestimenti
un'ultima cosa su cui voleva attirare la
vostra attenzione è il futuro
dell'artigianato l'artigianato sulla
carta è dato per quasi estinto in realtà
nella collaborazione con il designer e
quindi nella ricerca nell'apertura di
nuovi materiali di nuove ricerche di
nuove sperimentazioni anche tecniche
anche formali anche di gusto si arriva
ad aprire un nuovo mercato
e per questo che soprattutto ad esempio
le grandi manifatture francesi in questo
periodo stanno molto lavorando ad avere
ospiti dei designer particolarmente
sperimentali emergenti che facciano dei
workshop e studino delle delle nuove
modalità questo vaso che vedete in vetro
è stato realizzato dagli ad masters con
le vetrerie di bio famose per il vetro
con le bollicine d'aria visibili è una
forma brutale una forma poco nota e
stata ottenuta soffiando del vetro
dentro a una corteccia di sughero
peraltro in estinzione in quelle zone
quindi vedete si aprono nuovi mercati
quello del collezionismo quello di un
gusto anche più radicale comunque è una
prospettiva nuova che arriva dal fatto
che il designer non è più il cliente
dell'artigiano ma è un suo interlocutore
un rapporto orizzontale e quindi questo
è stata semplicemente una piccolissima
carrellata un assaggio di tutte quelle
che sono le interazioni fra i designer
contemporanei e le discipline più
diverse
viene da ridere un po viene viene
strano pensare come per alcuni si parli
ancora di design solo in termini di
arredamento e come qualcuno addirittura
dica che tutto è già stato disegnato
quando in realtà possiamo dire che tutta
ancora da disegnare
se se consideriamo queste interazioni
resta una certezza che è quella con cui
vorrei salutarvi chi lavora
all'innovazione oggi lavora in
interdisciplinarietà e il design è
sempre presente e collaborativo nel
lavorare a questo obiettivo perché al
centro del design l'obiettivo del design
è sempre l'uomo ed è per questo che è
così importante
grazie
[Applauso]